a new hydrogen factory off the i-15 and
apex exit in north las vegas is opening
up this month mary jane belliesa got a
tour of the facility she shows us how
the company is working to power zero
emission cars to reduce greenhouse gases
just miles off the motor speedway is the
air legate factory the company's goal is
to produce liquid hydrogen to supply the
transportation industry dave edwards the
director and advocate for hydrogen
energy at air lockheed says converting
to hydrogen for fuel is an energy saver
and will cut down on global warming so
if you think about those places in a
city like las vegas or in any any city
that has
heavy transit heavy transportation
sectors the particular emissions from
diesel from things like buses and from
trucks and and from cars themselves
those issues are addressed by battery
electric and fuel cell electric vehicles
because they have zero emissions at the
tailpipe the factory will convert
landfill gas and a purification process
to turn out low-cost low-carbon hydrogen
our production facility produces about
30 tons of hydrogen per day that would
be enough if you could take all of that
hydrogen and put it into fuel tanks for
light duty vehicles it would be on the
order of about 40 000 cars on the
highway currently around 20 people are
working at the plant they hope to expand
as this new market of transportation
fuel grows we know it's going to start
in california things usually do from a
transportation perspective if you've
seen anything from the california
markets you know that the shortage of
fuel and the the operation of the
stations has been limited by supply
chain and and so this should help
in a large degree to all of the the
consumers who are who are relying on
hydrogen for for day-to-day activities
and the startup of the north las vegas
plant is just the first step in
decarbonizing the transportation sector
as the company continues to expand here
in las vegas and across the west coast
reporting in north las vegas mary jane
vallieza live local now